uh i remember you telling me you met
barbra streisand and she wasn't very
nice
no i just didn't know what to say and i
knew she liked uh
uh aegon sheila that artist aegon sheila
who who i patterned a whole character
looking after
um so she was at a party at the the
those songwriters that wrote
a lot of her songs the maryland and
whatever whatever their names i don't
know they were there i was there with
michael feinstein
right and barbra streisand was there
with um
the director who did what's up dog who
wrote the book
right used to be with civil shepherd
anyway so
i just sort of stood there uh listening
to her talk
she said she looked at michael feinstein
and she said are you the um
like that he said yeah yeah so but right
when it was sort of
time getting time to close i said
i i know that you have some aegon
sheilas where do you keep them
this is a really strange question
and she got really defensive and said
why
and i said well i mean why i said i said
because
he's a favorite artist of mine and when
i heard that you
you you had some i wondered if if like
they were in a room or in a hallway
if they were in a room where you could
see them a lot of the time
or a hallway where you just could pass
bible so that's
and what'd she say i don't remember
she didn't want to talk she probably
listened but if at least i talked to her
once
that's true uh i talked to her once too
i talked to her
but more importantly was the time that i
lit betty davis's cigarette
tell me about that well i was at rodney
mcdowell's and he had i mean he would
have these
parties where people were over
i think this was i don't know if this
was a thanksgiving or not but i remember
uh elizabeth taylor was there um
um um
the guy who did the house of wax vincent
price
vincent price was there with his wife
betty davis elizabeth taylor
because i remember for desserts there
were different kind of
cakes which liz taylor was going crazy
and uh and betty davis sort of
hobbled into the room this was after the
dinner
and and and betty
this taylor said something like betty oh
come on look at all the cakes
and and somebody said something funny
that betty davis didn't like and she
hobbled away
and vincent price saw her and said oh
benny look at you you thought you were
so skinny but you got a little belly
and she really got angrier and walked
off
but it was it was it was quite a party
that
you mingled with some of the greats